The end of the 19th century,
the cigarette existed at the center of a
lot of different cultural forces.
The one you're looking at right here is
from a painting by Edvard Munch,
most famous for another canvas called
screen.
This self portrait with cigarette may
two years later,
though less jarring is just as concerned
with monks personal psychology and the
dark underside of his identity as the
scream is,
but to his critics in his hometown of
Oslow,
the portraits dark.
He's unfinished.
Feeling was not only unfit for art,
it was dangerous to the psychology of
the city and the age as monks.
Self portrait demonstrates he is by no
means a normal man.
When an artist is abnormal,
a shadow is thrown over all his art.
That's a quote by Johann
Scharffenberger,
Norwegian medical student who was
echoing align of conservative moral
thinking that feared the decay of
society resulting from art like that
monk and his contemporaries or making.
This pessimistic attitude was
popularized in a large book called
degeneration by this guy,
Max,
nor Nordell,
who attacked pretty much every kind of
art that wasn't up to his moral
standards as poisonous and corrupting
for Scharfenberg nor Dow.
The cigarette was symptomatic of
societies degeneration.
It was along with alcohol,
one of civilizations ugly indulgences,
but for monk and his circle of decadent
artists,
the cigarette was something much
different for them.
The end of the 19th century also
represented a change,
but it was a chance for a break from the
stale bourgeoisie values,
the prudish and uptight conservative
values of Nortel and his acolytes.
In 18 nineties,
Europe.
The cigarette still wasn't all that
popular.
Only 10 years earlier,
James Albert bond sack invented a
rolling machine which made it possible
to mass produce 200 cigarettes a minute,
but they were still dwarfed by the sales
of cigars and pipes.
The since the beginning when beggars in
Spain took the discarded tobacco from
Cigar Butts and reroll them.
The cigarette had always been associated
with the lower classes in the Crimean
war.
Soldiers Roll Tobacco and old
newspapers,
and by the 18 nineties when machine made
cigarettes were cheaper to produce and
by the working classes of Europe began
adopting the cigarette while the
middleclass especially the men stuck to
their cigars.
This lithograph by Thea fill steenland
captures the feeling perfectly.
Notice how the bourgeoisie man clad in
his proper dress and hat uses his cigar
to light the cigarette for the man with
the loose color who is clearly of a
lower social standing.
It was in the lower classes that monk
and his Bohemian contemporaries found
their alternative to the suffocating
middleclass value system.
They traded in drawing rooms for late
night cafes,
dinner parties for nightclubs and cigars
for cigarettes.
Cigarettes became the essential prop of
the Bohemian lifestyle in this painting
by mentor Christian Kroger,
you can see a 21 year old edvard monk
lighting up with his friends and fellow
painters in his studio in this etching
by Moog himself.
Smoke snakes and fills up the atmosphere
of a cafe where Bohemian intellectuals
of both genders drink and debate art and
ideas.
In other words,
everything Max nor Dow despised as
critic Patricia Berman.
Notes,
Bohemians of the 18 eighties and
nineties embraced the deviancy that
people like Nortel assigned to them.
They existed somewhere between the
middle class and the NRC of the streets
and their aesthetic revolt was the birth
of what we can see now.
Was cigarette cool for monks work.
This meant moving away from the
naturalism of his predecessors,
the scientific recording of the natural
world,
even moving away from impressionism,
which monks all as little more than
formal exercises with light,
his task would be to dig into his own
psyche and record subjective experience.
That's how you get something as
terrifying as the scream.
This is how dark subjectivity warps the
natural world.
As he wrote later,
I was walking along the road with two
friends.
The Sun was setting.
Suddenly the sky turned blood red.
I paused,
feeling exhausted and leaned on the
fence.
There was blood and tongues of fire
above the blue,
black fjord and the city.
My friends walked on and I stood there
trembling with anxiety and I sensed an
infinite screen passing through nature.
You read any diary or memoir of a suffer
of depression and you'll find similar
moments of disturbing transformation.
The truth is that mental illness was
underscoring this whole transitional
time in history.
As nations came to grips with the rapid
growth of anxiety,
depression,
mania,
and other mental illnesses,
different groups reacted in different
ways.
It's what's really at the heart of
Nordhaus fears of degeneration.
It's what a number of Bohemian artists
of the era were attempting to explore in
their work.
The tragic relationship between madness
and creativity is undeniable.
Some ran from that fact.
Others refuse to look away.
At this time,
there was a kind of catchall term that's
no longer really in use.
Neurasthenia,
something that's probably more akin
today to acute anxiety or mild mania and
here to the cigarette is significant
because there was a belief floating
around that cigarette smoking was one of
the causes of insanity.
A theory put forward in a book by Dr El
Brammer called tobacco insanity and
nervousness and another doctor,
the surgeon Theodore Bill Roth,
believed that the widespread cases of
Neurasthenia and neuroses were due to
alcohol and cigarettes.
Now,
if you look again at monks self portrait
with cigarette,
you can see a nexus of all these social
constructions.
Monk is aware of his critics,
their belief in his degeneration and the
cigarette as one of its causes.
He uses it as a formal reason why the
painting is nebulous.
It's shrouded in cigarette smoke,
but he's also using this dissolution by
way of cigarette to signal the
intersection between Bohemian life,
mental illness and art,
the prevalence of mental illness.
It's connection with genius and the
failure of Bourgeoisie moralizing to
come to grips with these realities.
He encoded the cigarette as a complex
symbol through which he asserted his
complex identity and created a site of
recognition for those who suffer today
because the problem of mental illness
has only grown and its growth has grown
to and we're not that much more
enlightened as to its causes than we
were then.
But I think that monks work is the
constellation because it proves that our
confusion about mental illness in
medicine and science will always be
matched by a probing and nuanced
understanding and art of all kinds.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
Welcome to my new apartment in Los
Angeles.
I just moved down here a couple days ago
with my girlfriend and it's actually our
one year anniversary today,
so if you're watching this,
actually you're definitely watching this
because we're in the other room watching
this together right now.
I love you so much.
Happy Anniversary.
It's been the best year of my life and
you're the best person that I've ever
known and I'm definitely not going to
choke up on this end screen,
so I'll just close it here by saying
I'll see you guys next Wednesday.